>> PETERSON: So, good morning, everybody.
My name is Dan Peterson. I'm a product manager
for Google Wave. I'm primarily focused on
the platform APIs and the underlying Federation
Protocol. So, glad to have everybody here
today. It's a big crew. We've got a lot of
stuff we can hopefully hack on. It's definitely
been a wild ride over the last seven weeks.
I think we've seen a lot of people experimenting
and prototyping with some of the APIs we have
available. We've also given out more than
6,000 accounts at this point, and we have
20,000 more requests in the pipe we're working
through over the next--in the next month or
so. We've also heard a lot of feedback about
the general usability of Wave itself as well
as sort of people who are starting to grok
the way it models. Certainly, things are very
early with Wave in particular. So, we're open
to lots of feedback and are iterating as we
go. We just want to involve everybody else
as we iterate to make this the best platform
possible. So, general flow for the day, well,
and--general flow for the day, we have--David
will be giving an API overview shortly and
Dan Marcelo will come up and do a tutorial
about the Java Robots API, and then we'll
take a quick break for lunch and bathroom
breaks and that kind of thing. And then we'll
do a panel for Q and A about the APIs and
maybe Google Wave in general if you have questions
like that. One logistical note, if you don't
already have your accounts--where is Allan?
So, first of all, double check your spam folders
because everybody in this room should have
gotten accounts. Allan Green was standing
over there or maybe he is--oh, there you go.
Allan over there in the blue shirt, if you
don't yet have your accounts, hunt down Allan
later. He's friendly. And let's see, at the
end of the day, after we sort of get in to
the hacking time, we'll have some time for
people to demo what they have been building,
some of the earlier prototypes and that kind
of thing. So, just a heads up for that and
we'll have beer arrive and that kind of thing.
So, next up, we actually have Lars Rasmussen
joining us from Sydney for quick announcement.
Know that it is 3AM in Sydney.
>> RASMUSSEN: Yes, hello. Good morning.
>> PETERSON: There you are.
>> RASMUSSEN: Hello, good morning. I don't
actually have anything to say. I think Dan
just really likes the idea of me being up
until three in the morning.
>> PETERSON: You said you're going to be in
pajamas.
>> RASMUSSEN: I was going to--oh, I'm wearing
pajamas. You just can't--the cameras just
couldn't zoom in too much. So, you know, you
guys, welcome, thanks for coming. I know it's
a lot of your time to come here for a full
Monday. I wanted to share a little bit about
our short term plans for Wave. So, you guys
are all on Wave Sandbox as part of our developer
preview. On September 30th, so in a little
bit more than two months, we're going to move
our preview from that separate sandbox build
onto the main Wave index on wave.google.com
that we're actually using now for dark footing
[ph] inside of Google and then we're going
to extend the scope of the preview beyond
developers. So we'll invite around about a
hundred thousand users starting, of course,
with you guys. By then, we'll have some tens
of thousands of developers in the Sandbox.
But we'll take, we have a lot of requests
from wave.google.com, from people that offered
to help find bugs and so on. And so we'll
invite them on board so that we'll have around
about a hundred thousand users starting on
September 30th. And what we're going to spend
our time on between now and then is three
things--well, four actually. It's speed. You
have noticed that you tried the Sandbox and
we've carefully have ordered the trap of premature
optimization. So, we're going to be working
on that a lot. It's reliability. We are going
to be, roughly speaking, taking it from the
alpha level quality that you are filling now
to something more like a beta so that mostly
you'll be able to get through a day's work
without any crashes. And then usability. There's
a good deal of usability problems that you
guys are facing, in particular, how to keep
your inbox calm and useful. And so those are
the things we'll work on. And one of the reasons
that we're sharing this--we don't normally
do this at Google, we don't normally share
plans for the future and so on--well, one
of the things we learned from back in the
maps days was in particular when you want
to get developers involved, which we obviously
do, it's a helpful thing to share future plans.
So, we hope we'll do well with this and we
need your help as well. We'd like to be able
to by September 30th maybe highlight some
of the things that you guys are building.
And so we've started seeing some early examples
of what people have built with Wave and it's
very exciting and so on, but they tend--of
course, this is still very early, to be fairly
small in scope. And so we're looking forward,
of course, to seeing really ambitious things.
We'd like to think that Wave can be used to
build really big and meaningful collaborative
applications. And if you guys are planning
something like that, so beyond what you can
build in a few days, let Dan and his team
know, and later we'll feature your extension
or your site imbedding Wave as part of this
whole thing of extending the preview at the
end of September. And so I want to say, and
we have done a few of these hackathons, and
I always emphasize that we want you guys to
be really ambitious and we want you guys also
to be demanding of us. We want that if you
build a site and embed Wave, then the Wave
should feel like a natural part of your site.
And if you build extensions for Wave, that
those extensions should feel to the Wave user
as if they were a first class citizen, a native
part of Wave. And we know that we don't have
all the hooks in place in the APIs to do this.
And, so, whenever you find yourself building
something that feels a little clunky, it doesn't
quite feel like it's part of Wave or it doesn't
quite feel like the Wave is part of your site,
let us know. Help us construct the right APIs
to make this possible. I know Dan and his
team loves nothing more than demanding developers
wanting more. Right, Dan?
>> PETERSON: Absolutely.
>> RASMUSSEN: Thank you. So, we're also going
to work on, of course, on the API. We're going
to--the actual installation flow for user,
installing the extension--I think we've just--just
today actually put some more code in the Sandbox
for that, but we're working on that. We'll
also build a gallery-like experience so that
users can find the extensions without necessarily
having to have them shared in the Wave with
them. And the last thing, I wanted to just
mention--we get asked this a lot about monetization.
So, we're keen to make Wave a viable business
both for us and for you guys. And one thing
that many people have suggested is whether
we could build some sort of applications store
where you guys could find different ways of
monetizing the things that you build. And
this is something we're thinking about. I
don't have anything to announce. I just want
you guys to know that it is something we're
thinking about. And with that, I'll hand it
back to Dan. You guys have a great time hacking
through the day. Who knows, maybe I will be
awake again by the time you guys end. Thank
you.
>> PETERSON: Good night, Lars.
>> RASMUSSEN: Indeed. Thank you.